[Music]
well thank you very much for coming and
I wanna say my name is andreas Giovanni
introduced and I was thinking about
actually suggesting a renaming at least
this day from a tutorial day into really
mental marathon Amsterdam mental
marathon because it's kind of if I look
at the agenda there's so many cool
topics and really I was thinking like
wow you really have to concentrate
actually eight hours so on a very
diverse set of things and I'm lucky
enough to be instill them in the first
part of it but then I thought well let's
not kind of cannibalize that and also I
made my mouth tacos with the with this
in mind so hopefully they're going to
cover some useful stuff but not really
requiring yet another half an hour of so
deep concentration so about myself
well as divine quickly introduced I
worked in spark and this one actually
this funny engagement profile is we work
a lot with with Microsoft and Microsoft
communities and they run they own sort
of smart algorithms that automatically
detect sort of the profiles of the
experts and at some point that that's
how I was kind of tagged and I actually
found that this is probably the most
relevant stuff I was never able to
explain like what I am exactly doing
because you know I've been coming from
high-performance computing from neural
networks as for my education then I
switch more into really development part
and into commercial then I got back into
actually add to the academia did my PhD
and then switch back again to to the to
the industry as they call it so what
essentially a work with with which data
on you know on on scale that's what I
would put it myself and our journey
today
is you know actually it I'm gonna start
a bid with with with the content context
and the motivation because I think I do
think still my talk is is probably not
really on the same level of details as
might that might usually happen here so
I have to introduce a bit of the concept
and the things because I don't think
that everyone is working with this
technology so I'm gonna use kind of
slide where in the PowerPoint for this
mainly and then once we move forward
we're going to really start building
some stuff and then I'm gonna use
basically Flipboard and web browser only
so I don't have any any local set up and
said the PowerPoint the only thing is I
need the Internet and yeah perhaps you
we can just collectively actually
develop the scenarios that support my my
conversation so the context is basically
about you know real time streaming
processes and what is real time
streaming processes was pretty broad
topic but in essence and this is where
my personal focus is as the focus is
basically an IOT and IT of course well
as I say for me is not device business
it's not things business but it's today
the business so I T itself you know it
generates a lot a lot of data was very
interesting also nature which has those
streaming nature and those kind of other
properties like and there's a lot of
broken data because you have to deal
with with real stuff and that is of
course a lot of a number of scenarios
you know which I don't think I need to
go really into details but you know from
all kinds of monitoring scenarios up to
more sophisticated you know cannafest
tracking routing up to the actually all
kinds of pricing analysis and and and
and and stuff like that usually
I think reference case outside IOT is
used like
detection on on running transactions you
know this kind of streaming data
basically where you have like a flow of
continuous flow of debt and you really
have to work on it while in at least
semi real-time close to close to
real-time because it doesn't have that
historical nature right I mean if you
have transactions
you really have to detect it as it as it
comes and not somewhat one day after so
that's a bit of context around
streaming data and its nature and its
its applications so actually I'm gonna
use a couple of building blocks I don't
want to talk that much about you know
Asher and cloud and stuff like that I
think some of you know you know what it
is and and and and the principles behind
that I'm going to jump straight away and
today I call the building blocks which
I'm gonna use to actually motivate and
illustrate actually end-to-end well a
solution how you know the data can be
you know ingested and then picked for
further analysis so an - event hubs is
one of those building blocks that I'm
gonna actually use so event hubs is
built and designed to basically
facilitate the ingestion of the data on
high throughput you know think about
megabytes per second of the input data
it is of course scalable it has certain
features like time retention buffer so
you can keep the messages inside the the
kind of the the the surface bus if you
will for a certain amount of time so
it's not really kind of a
fire-and-forget model and of course it's
it's scalable so it's completely pass
offering is basically you don't have to
manage any kind of infrastructure or
viet on machines and stuff like that so
you just get this building block
and you know you can start actually
ingesting your data it has actually one
in the way limitation on one focus it's
not on the same principle it's not
really built exactly on the same
principle as positioning as Kafka which
is probably many of you know so it has
limits on them on the message side size
so it's not really general-purpose kind
of you know data streaming hub has
really optimized for high throughput but
you can't send you know 40 megabytes of
of messages into it so it's actually
limited to a few hundred kilobytes so if
you look at I'm gonna quickly go over it
in essence you know you have this kind
of an IOT world and the data world of
big data world and the even hubs is just
in the middle so it's really an
injection mechanism with kind of where
you can push data from different kinds
of you know gateways or devices or
whatever and it's also you know
facilitates the consumption on on a
large scale of the data at the first you
know analysis and storage and and
processing whatever you do it so it's
really kind of a front-end which sits in
between the you know the IT data and
really the the data analytics which I
think most of us actually in a bit of an
architecture well it has this notion of
partitioning which some of you might
know from like you know no sequel
databases where you can basically kind
of control how the data is is
partitioned and split it supports
somehow somewhat also the the
scalability but basically you can
control by providing certain keys and
then based on that key your data is
going to be split into different
partitions and each partition is kind of
a queue where you know that the data
comes and then the data consumed you
know the of course the event producers
it supports to measure protocol HTTP and
AMQP so you know mgp's is basically as a
defector these days is standard protocol
all kinds of messaging but when it comes
to the IOT not all devices support for
example mq for various reasons and also
the difference is MVP is is you get live
connection so it's stateful and HTTP is
just you have to make a connection all
the time you know it's request response
bank so if you have like really high
throughput and within a certain amount
of time then you probably use m2p
connect to the event hub and then start
pushing the date and when HTTP of course
needs time and there is some overhead to
make the connection all the time and of
course then this is also an interesting
concept of the event receiver so event
receiver consumes the the data through a
so called consumer group and consumer
group which it's actually - it's quite
an interesting principle because it's
basically a logical view on offer event
hub that means that basically different
consumers can have they own independent
isolated you know view on on the data so
basically the advice is consumer group
is per receiver so if you have one
application that's one consumer group
the second application it's a second
consumer group so that they don't
interfere with each other way so that is
a bit of an on the receiving side and to
summarize so the throughput is they have
this throughput unit so one block is
actually 2 mega byte on on read and one
mega byte on right but then it's it's
it's it's scalable you can increase
those throughput units and it has this
also interesting notional which is
basically clients and curse
we're gonna come to this notion a bit
later because cursor is the one that is
actually the principle that allows you
to build the the consumption part right
because you have a streaming data and
cursor that's always like a moving slice
where you actually consume this data so
that is a bit of about event hubs the
second building blocks is called a state
bricks I don't know how many of you are
actually into the first spark we have
stayed the brig's business not that not
that many actually okay so that's what
that's what I've envisioned so actually
done before I jump into the edge data
bricks I just make a quick very brief
you know introduction or snapshot about
Apache spark because actually a cdata
bricks it's it's an offering that is
based on Apache spark and in essence all
the stuff that I'm going to talk about
is not personal data brick specific it
can be implemented in a you know open
source edition of Apache spark so I'm
going to just use the data bricks for a
various reasons including that I'm
actually over the last couple years I've
never done anything on on my local
machine so it's kind of you know it's
everything in in cloud and in the
browser and Internet and as soon as the
data is in the cloud then you know I'm
not not really working that much with
the managing yes as part laster's but it
is possible to build so apache spark
well it's sort of really the trial
position is like a unified framework for
for data analytics it basically has the
the core engine which is by default
based on sort of disputed computations
it considers it has some basic data
structures which are by default
distributed so whatever data you feed in
those data structures
get you know partitioned across the the
the machines and clusters and then the
computations happen so on top of that
core they have different schedules
schedulers so this is where actually the
jobs get get executed and then on top of
that that core engine basically those
had the major component so a spark SQL
this is actually like a sequel dialect
for actually well what you would expect
from sequel you know running and
interactive interactive queries there is
a library called spark Emily which is
actually it has some machine learning
algorithms implemented on top of the
distributed back-end which is by itself
a super non-trivial task the task and
those who are really deep into reading
machine learning know you know not
everything is paralyzed above and
disputable so it is somewhat from my
perspective well limited and constrained
for the reason that you know it has to
run on a large scale on a distribution
sparse streaming this is what we're
going to talk about today that's the
part and the API for streaming
processing and it also has some graph
API where you can work on a graph
related data so basically if you look at
this kind of sounds very cool because
there is more more or less everything
within one within one framework of
course it has support for all kinds of
also you know deep learning frameworks
for example but that is something
already which then needs to be done
custom and on top of it and that's not
really a default SPARC package so that
is a bit about spark so as I said the
architecture so it has this kind of
driver worker concept basically master's
slaves in a way where driver is
basically like the entry point for for
your quote for your program
where they say executed and then
everything gets distributed actually and
gets executed on the worker nodes and
then those worker nodes you know they
actually access the different data
sources and do all kinds of also like
caching to try to localize and optimize
the data so that you know the data gets
cached on when the local workers in an
optimal way and those kind of those kind
of things
it supports you know HDFS not only HDFS
but you know all the different kind of
data sources
gdb see all all kinds of databases of
course as three different edged storages
and it has of course the default cloud
so to say way is it's available in all
public clouds as a set of video machines
and I'm now talking about just the
defaults part offering so the PI SPARC
so what is actually the relation between
the PI spark and and SPARC I find it's
quite important so usually you come to
this diagram and I put this references
more details about actually the
internals so SPARC is written in in
Scala actually says it it's GBM based
environment however it supports as a as
a kind of client client or as a
front-end you can use are fightin and of
course Java Scala so we're going to talk
about a Python stream which is called PI
spark and actually how it works is that
there is actually a way where a GBM
Forks Python processes and then it
communicates with the Python processes
via pipes which is like an inter process
communication so one can say
of course the most optimized way of
using spark is still scallop or Java
because it's written Java so here you
get some of course overhead in within
this inter process communication but
it's not really a large overhead
comparing to you know the duration of
the whole computations the data taking
but in essence it's somewhat foreign
process which is then supported for each
each word each worker so that is that is
actually about sparked now I just want
to actually go into the into the edge
data breaks and what it is and well why
I find it's actually it's really a very
useful building block or component that
is that is available and I'm gonna I'm
gonna now switch into into the browser
and actually am I think it would be just
best if we follow my browser session
because of course well probably some of
you could have get a she uh she accounts
because actually everyone can get a she
for free with honey $50 credit as a
trial but thing is going to take too
much time if we start to kind of
organizing this however all this stuff
that I'm doing is going to be completely
repeat reproducible so I can export all
the the code and configuration that I'm
using so you can try or replay this
yourself so actually this is like
basically as a portal so I'm logged in
with my account and basically I have
this resource group notion so resource
group is like a logical way of group
different resources and here you can see
that I
have two resources that that I pre
created one is the the event hub and
second one is as data bricks services so
if I go to as data bricks it has that
notion of of workspace so I'm launching
the edge data bricks workspace and now
let's go a bit over what it actually is
so in Assam yeah sure that's good is
that yeah yeah okay yeah thanks so
basically this is what they called a
unified workspace so the workspace is
organized for each user so as a user
I've got my folder and then within this
folder I can you know create a new
notebook give it a default language what
I want to use with not with that
notebook and then associate that not
book to the cluster so it's kind of it's
very similar concept of course very much
inspired by you know what do you have in
energy and Jupiter however that's a bit
more coupled with the whole way of how
data bricks is is organized so if I
create a new notebook then I've get my
basically notebook where which is
attached to the running clusters cluster
and there I can you know start basically
writing the code important stuff is so
if we go into the into the cluster
this is cluster this is actually a spark
cluster which is I think one of the most
useful feature of edge data bricks is
you know you don't need to man
the cluster yourself here I can do a
cluster name I can pick the the runtime
so what kind of spark version do I need
what which Python version do I need I
can pick the different sizes of the of
the computing behind my driver and I can
also specify the size of the of the
actually computing ambition behind my
work right and here you get basically
different options and those are actually
the ones that that Microsoft has as as
just as a VM and there you can even
there is a GPU accelerated machines
coming so based on your expected
workload and the scale that you need of
course you you can adjust the the type
of the sizing that you need that you
need I'm gonna go for for just default
one and for avoiding gigabyte of memory
for course and then here is also another
interesting feature
it supports auto scaling so I can
specify the minimum amount of work nodes
and the maximum amount of work nodes and
then there is some heuristic that if I
begin Mike when I begin my computation
it starts with the minimum but then if
there is a pressure on you know a memory
and CPU then it starts out of scaling
cluster as the computation happens so
that and and and then the third one
which is quite important for from the
really usage perspective and operations
perspective is this one you can specify
the outer termination if the cluster is
not in use so if there are no jobs are
running the and then you know I can
specify half an hour or ten minions so
from 10 mins to two hours if it's not in
use than the classic gets automatically
so you don't have to pay for it which is
quite important in in the cloud and this
is I think something than this like wow
it is a strong how should I say that the
selling point you know then Sam can you
cluster or can Yoko answer also do this
that's quite useful so I can specify all
kinds of spark config and stuff like
that so I pre created already here the
the cluster yeah so data factory can
invoke notebooks that's out of the box
right now it's also sort of it used to
be in a better staff the this dispute
the the jobs part it is actually here a
native feature of the day of the data
breaks itself so here to the clusters in
the clusters you have two types of
classes you have the interactive
clusters this is where you work sort of
experimenting exploring the data but
then if we go to the to the notebook PI
and side here and this is I find this is
really a killing for the practical stuff
and especially from the kind of
transition from you know like data
science data engineering into really
like any kind of production operations
all the scheduling stuff you know that
something that is actually very
non-trivial thing to build to you know
to done you need to kind of CCI CG or
some kind of deployment into the new
class so here you can just schedule the
job and really use you know basically
cron syntax or just the manuals mainly
specifying and then it's gonna once it
runs it's gonna create the the job
clusters or from here I can also do it
backwards I can do the create a new job
I can specify the notebook or it can
still very much work with you know
binaries like like
and then I can specify the the type of
class right so I can configure the the
the cluster and also I can configure the
schedule but also an interesting part is
this one which is also quite you get it
kind of for free but you know it can for
example do an alert if the the job has
failed and then it can concern an email
notification and stuff like that which
is like you know otherwise needs to be
it needs to be a build so the the the
the job part at least well we use this
quite heavily and we kind of separate
the the notebooks if you talk about data
engineering which is data factory is so
the if there is some data transformation
in the notebook and not a job then it
can be triggered in from the data
factory but if you see a data factory
moyson end-to-end Orchestrator which
does you know first the data cleaning
data engineering part done for example
some scoring or some publishing then it
can still trigger the the notebooks that
do you know scoring for example but we
use it more for so the jobs let's say
what you would usually see is just a
data breaks and native form so we only
triggered really the data processing
data cleaning leaning part from this one
actually there is it has an it has an
API where you can of course do it has
REST API where you can up to submit the
job scratch-off so all that
functionality is actually also
replicated with with the with the REST
API so this is like you know macum from
the you know experience where you manage
you know to to really be productive so
to say and and to work with data I kind
of manage to skip this moment where in
you can use with data on the local
machine you know if I've worked with it
like satellite it but that's how I
started kind of working with data
satellite image the really the original
one that that for example then gets down
to Google Earth the size of it is 450
megabytes so one image where you have
the whole range than ultra range in
there etc so you know you have to think
how do you organize it and the only way
to organize well then you need to build
some kind of cluster right with all
kinds of MPI's and for its MPI or or
other things which is done you spend 80
percent of effort you know building
figuring out the infrastructure and this
is like really a matter of yeah you know
a minute which is to me I'm I'm still
very very excited about you know the
whole like clout it's not something that
it's like very far but it has this this
this benefit for for what we do and for
for what I do
so this cluster the job part of course
the workspace there are a lot of other
things which are also quite useful that
is of course the the admin console where
you know you can also do access control
who can do what and etcetera so it's
kind of built for really collaborative
work and of course not everyone for
example is allowed to spin often in you
a new cluster so that is a bit of a bit
of a data as data breaks apart which I
wanted to cover of course there is also
I have a pre-configured the div at the
event have but there is nothing really
special here I actually use it for
various purposes but you have you know
that's the stuff that we talked about
you know you can create different
consumer groups there is one by default
then you can get some telemetry some
some some monitoring what's what's going
on well not
is going on some throughput stuff
important is done is this one we're
gonna use it and share Texas policy is
that basically with the policy you can
organize more access perspective so that
quality means that the ones who used the
skis they can manage they can send the
the messages and they can also listen to
this so I just made it full full access
and this is done you get a connection in
a connection string for both for you
know clients and and and and and and and
and suppliers so this is a bit of of the
of the issue part is is there any like
na questions so far around around this
one yeah oh that's good that's good
that's a good question actually and
thanks he of course here in the cluster
you have two things you have still the
the native spark interface so here I can
go to spark UI and well the usual things
that you would execute what you expect
from you know optimizing and tweaking a
spark it's still there it's not it's not
really any kind of customized or patched
as part you get a default interface and
you can access to all kinds of spark
provided matrix talk to first of all to
get the the details into into spark
right so that is level one the level two
of course
probably you're talking about the
underlying you know VMs and computing
site but those VMs day and know what
difference different than the default
you know if you for example want to
install you know Linux you go to the
portal say I just want plain VM and then
they're going to be a lot of sizes and
of course those VMs they have different
characteristics like they have different
generations of CPU the storage is behind
this different you get an SSD storage
and the more the regular storage those
kind of things but this is not really
specific to this part so you can see use
your you know spark with utilization and
of course what is the optimal
configuration of this this is the
question which is like you know there is
not really a straightforward answer to
this you would need to investigate yeah
what is the what is actually the optimum
they have some categorization like for
example storage optimized or this
compute optimize this F H they use
latest generation of of Intel processors
but of course then they are more
expensive you know this is kind of the
balance that you need to make this does
that answer the question or no I would
what then what do you what exactly
looking for
yeah it has no that but this is all
still it's a spark specific things right
I'm not seeing in what way it's it's
it's it's a specific it has some some
scheduling ways which is again
spark specific so if you job runs one a
one-hour on the same data set I can't
see why it's going around two hours on
the same cluster size on the same data
set of course if you have ten acid jobs
running at the same time that the taking
resources but this is a tip this is any
kind of framework has that issue I mean
from MPI to just default sparked right
so optimizing for this is it's a viewer
and it's probably a separate separate
topic I I think because I'm not quite
sure how that can how that can be
answered sort of in a very concise of
course yes yeah I mean do you get I mean
this is the this is the well view of
sort of visual stuff but this also
information you can also you know
consume and automate but there is
nothing I would say that that the data
breaks specifically adds on top of this
of course they optimize the the engine
but that one you know it for us it's
given and at this point you have really
a very detailed access the usual spark
one and when it's running then of course
it's it's it's it changing and and you
see what's going on but then yeah of
course you can put it somewhere else for
more detailed analysis and
and stuff like that so that is that
would be my probably ultimate ultimate
answer so in any other remarks at this
point yes you can actually in there the
concept is they call it no notebook
driven workflows or something basically
there is a way you create like an entry
point which is a notebook and then the
only thing that notebook that notebook
does is in invoking the as a notebooks
so you compose your Jobson because the
the entity is a notebook it still runs
in notebook and there you can also for
example programmatically specify like
the timeout the exception handling and
stuff like that so you have a Python
like main function which invokes the
this the the sub flows which are
notebooks themselves and then the wake
out how you handle it what kind of
timeouts what you do with exceptions and
you can control it yourself so it's not
really like to be it's it's not really a
replacement I think for things like you
know air flow dead faxer is not really
from the orchestrating isn't it's not
that powerful and it's not supposed to
be but if you have more your code is
somehow composed in different notebooks
then you're gonna have a main function
that just invokes them sequentially and
doesn't make sense to invoke the second
one if the first one has failed but it's
not really a replacement for this for
the kind of an end-to-end you know
orchestration frameworks from from my
from my perspective even though of
course you can build it in because if
you just buy them so basically this is
like yeah about about this
so now let's join a jump into the into
this part and this is where
[Music]
I think we're gonna slowly move from the
from the slides into actually according
because I have clustered I have you know
notebooks so you can start actually
doing also just want to probably quickly
make some reference so the there is this
notion which is called continuous
applications and this is the notions
which is very much
promoted by by data bricks themselves
and data bricks does the company
actually that is founded by the original
spark creators and they're kind of still
major contributors into open source park
itself but also they run this data
bricks as a company and then they have
also AWS kind of offering and issue data
bricks that's a close collaboration
between Microsoft and data bricks to
make it really the default Microsoft
offering just about what data bricks is
it because I'm referring to the data
Briggs so they promote this notion of
continuous application continuous
implication is basically when you look
at especially from the streaming
perspective like most of the use cases
they are not really actually streaming
only so if you look at this side you
know like input then you have some
computation and then you know you put it
somewhere into some output that usually
actually not the case and most like most
frequently not at all so the obvious
reason why it is not like this because
especially if you talk about the IOT the
size of message is very is very critical
so from those devices you get really
only the let's say the sensor specific
data which is optimized or should be
optimized for size because you know you
don't want to use your network bandwidth
so where the type of data that you get
here is really very specific to a device
which might get some kind of device ID
or something like that but the you know
as for example the data scientist well
you need to have some enriched and data
set right so you you can't really
work with device IDs and their location
because it's barely means nothing and
not useful so what happens immediately
than to do this you need actually join
or enrich your streaming data with with
data from your you know CRM system so as
catalogs what does that divine mean does
the divine mean for example or other
thing so this kind of in reaching the
streaming that this is one of the
obvious thing that this that is coming
into into mind and then on top of this
in rich data you of course have
different perspectives right as more
exploration perspective which is the
call that Hawk queries you can do of
course still send some the output the
process output somewhere and think
that's the kind of tunnel that does that
or and this is quite important this is
the fundamental principle that actually
spark is positioned to actually be
different
among the other streaming frameworks day
the principle is here is that basically
if you have streaming data or let's say
in simple words the the certain piece of
the of the streaming data which is
coming for example of last and 10
minutes the result of this invocation of
some Cottam on top of that piece of
streaming data it should be consistent
with as you would be executing just
static
vej job on top on top of this date which
is kind of sounds very naturally and
very logical but that is not really a
trivial
my requirement what happens is let's say
the if the data is it needs to be
analyzed in real time then there is some
streaming framework is being used and if
there is some report for example has to
be produced on top of the data then the
data is stored and some some other
mechanism is used to to work on the same
data set and so what happens is the most
often they can produce different results
because you know you don't work with the
LDL data things are failing and etc so
having that consistency this is a quite
important and this is actually very
natural to look at and this so as I said
consistency the other one is fault
tolerance as you think if you think
about this the this the the distributed
streaming is actually quite challenging
tasks because if you build the side
framework you know things are failing or
even your notes in the classroom are
failing so if you start kind of you know
if this is your in I'm gonna slowly
switch also to the flip board let me
know you know if this is your input and
then if you have this kind of you know
Map Reduce more kind of stuff you know
where oh you have different like pieces
kind of coming together right but first
day you know you split the data you
partition it you put one piece here one
piece here and then you kind of joined
the results back so what happens if that
if that guy fails you know this is like
the obvious thing you really need to
guarantee here the because we are really
talking about the streaming data which
is quite important it has this you know
time order perspective so having that
fault tolerance is extremely important
otherwise you might still get data and
this is where the the third one is
coming you know the data sometimes might
come what this is so called out of order
so when the time when the data got
produced for some reason for example the
no internet connection so the data has a
timestamp but then it was sent in a
different moment of time so you don't
want to deal with those things and
actually sparks teaming deal deals with
this it kind of guarantees that out of
order date of the data that was
delivered here later it had at the
processing side we can still expect is
to be you know continuous stream so
those are the things that that actually
makes a spark quite interesting
or actually quite useful and it's being
used a lot I think 60 percent of spark
use cases at least that's what I read
are actually streaming data because
because of those features so I think I'm
not going to go too into March into into
this stuff but actually the principle is
is this one the data stream data is
basically like an unbound and table so
you should see it this the data stream
is considered basically as a table where
the rows are abandoned that's that's the
that's the basic principle and then once
the table that the data is always
abandoned so once you can see that
everything is a table where the rows the
incoming data is get continuously
offended then you can actually work and
with on a streaming data the same way as
you would be working on on the badge
static data and of course well with with
the time then you know things get get
get appended and to not think this time
serious well it's it's obvious and this
is logical what you would explain right
so if you look at at the time the input
table grows but then the output gets
taken is basically first-in first-out
can principle but implemented on one
large on a distributed manner so it has
a lot of built-in sources I'm going to
use edge data
as your event hubs as a source and now
going to switch into the into the
completely into the notebook show
actually I'm sure how much how much time
do I have
I have half an hour right yes so I kind
of created this this model or scenario
that I wanted to use so imagine we have
a parking garage with a lot of parking
space and then each parking place is
this morning to earth with the sensor so
and that sensor is streaming the data
and then I came up with this model you
know what is in this data well there is
a license place played the the the sport
ID so which sport is is taken of course
the the time stamp when it happened and
the the type of event operation as a car
entering or living so we have sensors a
bit more smarter than than this one and
so that is the model which I want to
kind of illustrate how can we really
work in such kind of setup with a sheet
data bricks and combined with even hubs
so what I'm going to do right now of
course well I don't have the part the
test parking garage so what I've done is
I have the the emulator which really
streams the data in this model so in in
essence what happens is wait a moment
it's not this is this one so when the
car entrance enters it kind of generates
the the event with those data set and
then I have some emulation that the car
remains parked between 0 and half an
hour and then it leaves and then when it
leaves if the event get gets generated
so that is a bit of my my model so I'm
gonna I'm gonna run this this emulator
to see you know on one side and on the
other side I'm gonna switch to this so
basically I prepared some kind of
boilerplate in in essence so first part
is of course the connection to the event
hub so as you can see if an have is a
default format that is and that is now
supported so that support was built by
by Microsoft and then this connection
string I took from the from my event hub
settings and this guy is now you know
streaming the the event now if I stop
this and I start running the the stuff
so actually as you can see here and this
isn't cool stuff about using notebooks
it derives the schema of the of the data
frame that represents my stream and
within this stream you can see actually
the body the body is quite important
because actually this is the message
itself that is being sent and this this
part are the the ones are specific to
event have you know like offset a
sequence number in queue time etc so
this one is quite important to work with
the stream data because offset is the
one is actually the position of the
message in queue so without actually
getting the data I get already the
schema of the of my of my stream so if
I'm gonna now do this so it gets into
some initialization and
let's see I can I can have some you know
here some actually way of seeing you
know input rate versus processing rate
well of course I'm not streaming that
high throughput so it's kind of very
much much the same and then I also see
the batch duration because what happens
is that the streaming data is how it
works is still being converted in little
batches that are being moved over the
incoming data and no-self that is the
position inside I also have raw data I
can see well how many records per second
and etcetera but and it is running so
this is a continuous saw and this is
here I can see actually my data the one
that is being streamed here is being
streamed here I can see actually the
real data so is not that much useful at
the moment because what we obviously are
interested in the body but body so it
senses AMQP it's binary protocol it's
binary she realized utf-8 JSON message
so the original message is is JSON
encoded but of course it got it got she
realized so if I just I can cancel this
for the moment but this is like the
first actually very interesting
principle that you know you get
immediately an abstraction offers over
something that is actually quite
complicated but you get it in a way that
it's it's a structure it's data frame is
exactly the same structures you would
get it by working with data from
database or or data Lake and you it gets
a schema and you can you can actually
have all those all those benefits
available so what we're going to do here
is of course this data
well it needs to be converted and what
happens is here is basically we need to
just do this this usual thing which I
guess a lot of data engineers or most of
us do is do all kinds of casting and
conversions to the data types that we
would like to use right so the offset is
is actually it's long so the the incue
time it's a timestamp the body we will
get it back to the to the string and
then this one we select just for fields
because we don't actually we're not
interested with with the rest so this is
like basically a typical Python thing to
work with to really a cast and do all
kinds of type conversion no interesting
thing is here you can see this Wis
column and then cast and then you
produce another data structure because
the the data frames they are in
immutable so you can't just say rename
the column or replace the the type you
have do a transformation which maps the
original one to the news to the new one
and then do select so that is basically
why it's it's a bit verbose comparing to
if you would have like you know in
pandas you can be renamed I think things
in planes planes and this is like the
typical thing when I started with spark
afterburners like how do I do this and
you can't rename because it's immutable
so you have to think in France
transformations but this is what
actually happens so I run this again so
input stream we kind of forgot already
that you know the data is actually being
being streamed so I've got my a new new
schema and well I can also display it
that's it's my personal way of doing you
know when I do some transformation then
display and see kind of what happens oh
that's already way more useful because
here we can see we can converted our
binaries to string which is done
represents the my JSON right that is
supposed to be streamed by device
so not to keep that trying I did some
mall also license plate generator but it
doesn't produce really something that
probably Dutch would recognize but
anyway I think it's not that important
so this is important the operations as
you can see some cars are leaving some
cars are coming this is this is the
times the time stamp if you if you look
at that this one is because I emulate
the time and some time is actually
already in the future because in my
emulator I add like half an hour that
the car was parked but reality is of
course well we did it in a couple of
seconds so this is good right
so far so good body and we've got the
body so then of course we want to
convert it into something that we can
actually work with and for this part
there is a way in spark to define
actually schemas of the time so we
define because if we look at the JSON
here and we know what kind of input is
we can specify the schema so the schema
convert the basically string or any kind
of unstructured data they can be
actually quite complex type all kinds of
nesting it converts into really a
tabular a basically view so we specified
the schema and it also constrains if the
the data is not compliant with with the
schema then what happens is for example
if I would not specify one of the fields
it would just keep it so I would not get
I would only get the part that that I
specified so we've got this now what are
we gonna do here is let's say we do cars
[Music]
so we've got our our messages right and
this is still streaming what we want is
we want to convert from JSON the column
body from from Jason
to applying this schema and again we
need to make it an alias called date or
something because otherwise the new
column is going to be generated so it's
not in place conversion it's a
transformation so each selection is the
transformation we make the the alias and
then do this trick we do it select again
with this dot star it allows us to
actually explore all the all the fields
right so we've got at this point the the
data column and then we want to really
select those those columns so we've got
now we've got data frame that actually
now here we go
so at this point actually it is a matter
of fact it's just I I do it in different
cells that's a bit of a way I can do in
the neck and also you know executed and
to see and at this point as you can see
it's a running still stuff so it's a
continuously running stuff but we've got
an abstraction that is basically the
same data frame as we would be using a
static data right and we've got staff
columns already expanded by using this
from jason method that's a built-in
spark there's nothing and that i've
built here and the schema that I was
just specifying so basically this is
like the basic principles that emulate
you know this part and this is what
called you know structured structure
streaming that's why it's called
structure because it's actually relies
on some on some back-end and then we are
really forced to to specify this and
then at this point yeah we've got just a
regular data set which is is you see it
running and it uses append mechanism by
default so it's kind of lazy data
structure because obviously
as soon as we start using either for
example wants to do the this which is
another interesting feature of of this
notebook you get these different
visualizations by default and here we
can for example visualize so as you can
see here we can visualize this our
streaming data peeking some operations I
call this ops so ops is 0 is entrance
and one is is leaving so we can still
see you know in in in in in real-time
this also gets updated so how many
different cars are coming and and and
leaving so you know which is like here
it has this batch interval right so it's
really semi but not really in that sense
real-time as people would say but it's
quite low latency still you know five
second batch and we get this updated so
this is already like you know to build
that use case having in my scenario what
is only missing is the real you know
devices and sensors because I have the
emulator but if there will be to come
this to like basically in half an hour
think this is a very productive way of
doing things and especially all kinds of
you know prototypes stuff like that so
at this point of course we can zoom and
generate all kinds of scenarios where we
would probably
we can imagine with this but then at the
end of the day it would be still along
the lines where we would be applying
some functions you know on top of this
so I think for this for the streaming
part and this is what I wanted to show
at this point and then of course the
interesting part what begins is you know
you have this more interactive part so
one scenario is really working with the
with real-time data for example I don't
know alerting something is in some some
system if the garage is full right there
you don't need a historical data you
really need to put some some some
detector on top of on top of the data
that you get however there is a lot of
useful stuff our staff can be done with
this data from the you know more data
science perspective and for advanced
analytic perspective right so we can
zoom into for example what's the what's
the average duration that car stays or
if we know some license plates some
insight about this so there is a lot of
stuff that can be done based on the on
the historical data and actually now I
want to show how to kind of facilitate
this and
but now it's no saw something what this
is this is symmetric I think now it's
like yes right this one yeah yes so
basically this is as I said the swimming
data and there is a trick to convert
this streaming data into something which
will be considered as a basically
historical data so here will be gonna
use the same thing so we've got our
messages which is an abstraction but
then we can we can start writing this
right stream this is actually done the
output so disk so called the output sink
so each thing is still something weird
each of the of the of the of the input
one also has the derive the right stream
so that allows to write into all kinds
of outputs including you know more
relational databases and and other
things and then we can do this trick
basically right right into memory and
give it a name and give it a mode so it
creates mam in in memory stream which
then basically can be considered as a
sort of thing as the temporary
persistent storage for for debugging you
know and kind of doing all kinds of more
static data stuff because otherwise I
would need to write this data than
somewhere into database or other things
which it's probably going to take even
more time to and to do so if I do it and
like this we initial and initialize this
this memory and stuff and I'm gonna kill
this one so now we started basically
that conversion from our
or messages which is already a
structured way into the into the memory
output which we gave it the name car and
then at this point we can actually start
running chico like queries you see on
top of top discards which is which is
all ended this one so we can pause
actually it's it's really if you think
about it it's it this way it already
becomes quite complex you know kind of
composing if f if like functional
programming people would say you know
like composing streams that is something
that goes like you know you really have
to be in a championship league kind of
two to really develop this because and
especially only in distributed fashion
so that's another thing that makes me
quite actually excited about this this
kind of composition and really it's so
simple abstraction you get you know data
frame and the stream that's the thing
and the transformation and then you kind
of compose things around and you don't
even feel that is you know that is that
is not not non-static data so what I
also want to show you is some things
that are not actually supported even
though it would be really cool to and to
have them like I was asking myself here
what can you what could you do with with
the data and the obvious thing that
comes to my mind is detecting the you
know the duration of stay right and to
do this digression of day of states also
not really not trivial you need to have
this so-called window primitive which
basically allows you to partition your
day because actually what we need to do
is we need to sort it by ops and the
license plate right in the decrease in
water and then do a difference between
current role and the next one that would
give us a duration state right so if you
have time we need to reach
and that is if you think about it on a
distributed data frame because you can't
universally and and navigate as you
would do it in a sort of imperative
language so that is actually the way to
do it so what do you do what you do is
you actually still need to create a new
column that represents the the at the
difference and basically then what we
are trying to say is you have this this
leg function with this one which
actually does the whole trick on such
kind of data sense so what it does this
one attribute it allows to actually make
an operation over not over the columns
but over the rows so what it says is
it's it's very declarative right okay so
I need to cast it to two integers and
then do the the - the the neck at the
current row versus the one beyond and
this is typically what would do the
trick
however here the interesting part is we
need them to so partition wise is you
can see this like a group it's like
grouping right but this one if I
actually execute that it's going to say
that the partitioning is only supported
on one time series so if this column is
each time which is which is kind of
obvious if you think about it especially
in terms of this out of order data so
you are not that flexible to do such
sophisticated things on on streaming on
streaming data but I just wanted to keep
this in in a notebook so that actually I
think we could I now replace as this
usually I think people don't talk
explicitly about things that are kind of
failing even though at this point it's
interesting it derives the new structure
but this as soon as it is lazy so at
this point I was actually still quite
happy because and so wow they are gonna
do it but this is where it makes it it
converts it really executed from lazy
just an abstract data structure which
has a structure but no data and really
starts it really needs to and here is
what the chance this is actually
exception if you go to spark code and it
checks the types of the of this ones and
and then throws throws this exception so
you know still there are some ways and
actually if you think about it probably
the duration you would need to see it
more from the historical perspective but
sometimes those those limitations are in
place also what is actually possible is
I was showing it with the memory is
possible to of course write it in a more
in a persistent storage so here I have
the can delete this one popping up so
again I still relate to my input stream
to the really original ones that keeps
keep still track off and I'm gonna shut
it down because and then again this is
just a different syntax actually it's
not about a Python and native but you
can invoke the the sequel of primitives
on the Python data structures so by
using this and then of course we always
need to do this conversion because I'm
going back to the input stream right to
the original one where the body is still
a binary and then again applying the
same trick with the schema
transformation
and this way I get my another type of
actually I think I should do it because
then it gets nested stuff and that
should be yeah
so that that flattens the again the
streak where you go you know like if you
do it without this right you get this
field that is a structure by itself and
then it gets nested but we would like
most likely to you know work with with
just a flat so I've got that my archive
data and then actually actually I can
write two more persistent output
location in that case I use data bridge
comes with local file system where you
know I can use it as a local file system
and this is actually also interesting
checkpoint location so this is what you
would be using more for production
setups the checkpoint location it's you
know because those streams if you run it
in production well things fail or other
things bad things happen so that the
stream gets interrupted so the
checkpoint location it's like it from
from certain within a certain time frame
it commits the data that is in the
stream and saves it to a permanent
storage so that you can reconstruct so
if something fails you rerun the same
query in the future it's gonna you know
pull the the committed part from this
checkpoint location and then continuing
with the with the live one so this is
another interesting moment where you can
basically replay the string replay the
stream this is how they how they call it
which is a principle that is also behind
this this framework and checkpoint
location modes its storage and this one
is then I put this my test data and then
I can kind of run this I'm still quite
surprised that nothing
works in one side and keeps running and
then if I look at at the at this for
example that there is no really good way
to know to navigate but I can look at
this it's kind of a file browser if you
will it of course it created this and it
stores it actually see realises if you
can see here it uses parkade format
which is way more efficient of course
and then it she realizes the the parts
of the data in the Burkett format in
orbit can be whatever format but when it
comes to more data like type of things
that's what's more optimal and all kinds
of CSV so you can see here that you know
the check parts it has more complicated
stuff but my test data this is the staff
that is where I actually write it into
the into the output so that one is is
also working so I got back I created
this up front also consume parts so as
soon as I stored this so someone else
imagine like data scientists can
actually already start using this data
and this is very simple so I can just do
this and you see it reconstructed so I
use it usually you to use the folder and
none it depends of course all that
Burkett and parts and you do it like
this so that you can already start
working on some slices of historical
data which is stored in the wall that's
not really permanent because if I
restart the cluster then it's gone but
it can be all kinds of permanent and
data so that is like a really a
permanent storage sort of interactive
part what I also was planning to show is
something that this is called stream
stream joint which is relatively new
feature so you can actually do joins on
to streaming on
dreams you know when you have like I
came up with this idea where your for
example have one stream that I have and
the other stream can be like some
payments mechanism where some license
plates you know they do some like
monthly ticket or something so that
stream would actually generate the this
kind of license plate and a duration so
it can be emulated actually just by
pulling a JSON file into into the
storage but thing it's gonna well then
you can basically you know imagine that
this is the stream and then you would
just again read this stream and do the
join and you would have done a third
stream that this is join of of two
streaming data the thing is that I so
didn't find a way pragmatic way to
because then we need to look into the
the license plates are generated so I
don't have the emulator that generates
these payments but basically should have
another stream that would be like this
for example we can save it actually the
funny thing is that you can consider
also a file system as a source for your
streams so it doesn't need to be a sure
even have in that case is you know I
just stored this file right you see it
here just imagine we would have it so
and I can get it back so if we do it
without joins you see and I've got my
shot that is already the stream which is
the source there it was event hub but
here the source is just valve file
folder and so if I put a new file here
that's what I thought kind of doing
right so you can do it like this and
then this and and then I can still do it
and then if I do it this right you see I
didn't rerun this because I but I put
two five two files in the file system so
usually this is his scenario by itself
where you do all kinds of Logan Alice's
for example where someone is saving the
log files and then you can use that
stream
you see it got two so if I put the
another one whatever and so I just write
the file right now
I offer cover wrote it so that one
should pick it up yeah here we go that
is actually more convenient actually way
to test this streaming and then I can
join this just by using join but this
license plate I'm not going to get any
any outputs because those are not the
ones that are generated so that is
basically this the the so we covered you
know the interactive part or I still
made it a bit for the reference the bad
stuff which is you know the sequel staff
and the the streams team joins which is
actually also enables quite an
interesting scenarios and from there on
basically thing we have a couple of
minutes to Q&A session and otherwise I'm
still here we can pick ups have it more
detailed look into something so yeah
thank you very much and if you have any
questions I think we have a couple
minutes
[Applause]